[Musique]
bonjour ver bienvenue au du thére
à bonjour monsieur vonique card maire
des clés sousbois vous êtes deè
viceprésident de la communauté de
commune de l'Ouest parisien voilà ça
c'est pour les présentations sommaires
l'endroit vous plaît vous préférez ça au
plateau télé habituelè sympa et on
aimerait bien avoir ce type d'endroit
sur la ville aussi vous savez qu'on va
parler de vous de votre parcours c'est
un exercice où vous êtes plutôt à l'aise
ou quelque chose que vous n'appréciez
pas trop parlez de vous quand on pose
pas de questions j'ai pas l'habitude de
parler je vous dis ça parce qu'on parle
souvent de la pipolisation de la vie
politique alors pas du tout ou pas du
tout ça vous n'appréciez pas non non non
pour vivre bien il faut mieux vivre
jeall dire discrètement vous nêtes pas
une politique de formation aussi on va
peut-être le préciser parce que vous
êtes diplômé d'une école de commerce
vous avez été commerçante avant de
passer tout à fait j'étais aussi dans
l'administration je travaille dans
l'export aussi avant de d'arriver en
politique et je suis arrivé en politique
entre guillemets complètement par hasard
cétait en 95 95 où j'ai été élu t de
list de l'opposition dans une ville
communiste oui c'éta une ville
communiste vous êtes arrivé avec votre
étiquette de centre sans trop de droitit
non pas vraiment en fait on est venu me
chercher en 95 3 mois avant les
élections parce qu'il y avait deux
listes à gauche et on souhaitait qu'il
deux listes à droite et bon j'avais
arrêté de travailler depuis quelques
mois et j'assistais au conseil municipal
au Conseil municipaux parce que ça
m'intéressait et
la personne de l'opposition est venue me
chercher et il s'est trouvé qu'il
cherchait une deuxième personne et on
m'a proposé et je me souviens toujours
quand je suis rentrée chez moi le soir
mon que j'ai dis sa Marie il m'a
dit il s'est assis et j'ai dit qu'est-ce
que tu en penses il m'a dit ben avant
dit de toute façon à avant de dire non
réfléchit parce qu'il y a des questions
qu'on ne posera jamais de fois et j'ai
trouvé que c'était un vrai défi et voilà
c'est comme ça que je suis arrivé vous
avez réfléchi vous êtes engagé en
politique mais avec quelle idée derrière
de faire changer les choses sur la
commun en politique en tant que tel je
me suis engagé parce que j'avais envie
de m'engager pour la
commune mais il fallait une étiquette
malgré tout c'était quand même un
engagement après après oui après
effectivement oui parce que il faut
savoir un petit peu comment les
personnes se situent par rapport aux
valeurs qu'elles défendent il y a un
problème de lisibilité allementand et
effectivement donc après je moi j'étais
inscrite dans un parti politique ù
j'étais à MP à l'époque àump maintenant
plus centriste he je suis centriste je
suis au Parti radical depuis quelques
années et 2001 élection pour un premier
mandat à la tête de de la commune oui
alors après je suis parti aux États-Unis
pratiquement quelques mois après avoir
être rentré dans l'opposition je
revenais en France de temps en temps
pour
justement continuer à la vie municipale
et parallèlement j'ai fait une formation
aux États-Unis qui m'a un petit peu
permis à mieux connaître le monde le
monde politique et aujourd'hui c'est
votre trème mandat vous avez été réélu
dès le premier tour en 2014 on va parler
de tout ça on va continuer la discussion
on vaer s'installer en salle allez-y je
vous
[Musique]
suis Véronique cotéia il y a quelques
minutes on parlait de votre engagement
en politique alors vous nous aviez dit
ça arrive un petit peu après ça arrive
cette C engagement au centre centre
droit vous êtes pas arrivé tout de suite
avec une étiquette en politique non non
c'est donc j'avais des convictions donc
effectivement ma famille de familial qui
était plus RPR après donc il y a l'UMP
et mon engagement au niveau du Parti
radical est arrivé plusieurs années
après oui alors parti radical qui fait
partie aussi de l'UDI vous êtes à l'aise
aujourd'hui au sein de cette formation
ah totalement oui totalement oui parce
que on se rejoint sur beaucoup de de
leur commune oui je prend regarder les
dernières déclarations avant de qu'on se
rencontre aujourd'hui la prise de
position de Jean-Christophe Lagarde le
patron de Ludi qui est favorable à un
accueil massif des réfugiés ça c'est un
vrai sujet d'actualité des réfugiés
venus d'Irak et de Syrie mais il demande
d'arrêter l'immigration familiale et que
les réfugiés fassent des travaux
d'intérêt général vous trouvez ça bien
vous êes je ne pas totalement je pense
que c'est un sujet enfin c'est difficile
de répondre à un sujet aussi complexe
avec une avec une réponse simple je
pense que c'est notre notre honneur
comme l'a dit le le Premier ministre
d'accueillir effectivement des personnes
qui sont persécutées ou menacées de mort
demand de la France comme
dit demander des contreparties j'auris
j'auris envie de leur dire les former
pour qu'ils puissent travailler voilà
j'auraai une autre formulation d'accord
tout est dans la formulation
effectivement on va revenir sur cette
question des réfugiés parce que ça
touche l'ensemble des communes de France
juste une parenthèse toujours sur votre
famille politique en vue des régionales
il y a eu un rassemblement entre les
centristes cent droit et puis et puis
les républicains c'est une bonne chose
Parti radical reste audible malgré tout
çaoui oui je pense que j'ai c'est une
bonne chose après au partis à l'UDI de
faire entendre sa voix c'est vrai que le
parti l'UDI et plus particulièrement le
Parti radical ont des valeurs très
humanistes d'où d'où la position aussi
de Jean-Christophe la garde sur ce sujet
mais au contraire je pense que les
Français en ont assez de toute façon des
des histoires de de partis politiques h
on devrait même ne plus par partir mais
d'intérêt général et et de se rassembler
sur sur des valeurs communes vous dites
l'UDI Parti radical qui reste audible
l'UDI malgré tout qui a des difficultés
hein financières libération parlait
récemment de faillite presque pour l'UDI
oui alors là j'avais pas cette
information là ça va m'inquiéter au
niveau de nos cotisations nous allons
être très bientôt mis à contribution
davantage va mal financièrement ou ben
écoutez j'espère que l'IDI par ses
élections aura des des candidats et qui
permettront de par leur participation à
remonter les les
caisses du parti on en revient à la
question des réfugiés est-ce que vous
allez en accueillir sur votre commune
sur les clés nous sommes en réflexion
nous sommes en train de recenser les
besoins que ENF les besoins que nous
avons et les et les possibilités que
nous pourrions avoir sur le principe si
nous pouvons même si c'est qu'une
famille je je souhaiterais par comment
dire solidarité pouvoir le faireme S
s'agit d'une famille à versaill la
préfecturequ i le centre des mort qui
accueille plutôt des militaires ouais la
préfecture pourrait aussi réquisitionner
je sais pas un gymnase une structure sur
la commune c'est envisageable je après
tout est envisageable je ne pense pas
qu'on en soit là au moment où je vous
parle après effectivement si c'est comme
ce qui se passe en Allemagne au
détriment des enfants qui peuvent plus
pratiquer leur activité
sportive il faut pas que l'accueil des
réfugiés permette de monter les
populations les unes contre les
autres ça serait le P un petit peu le
risque he parce qu' a quelques mois des
élections c'est un petit peu ce qui se
dessine malgré tout qui pourrait arriver
il est pas question pour la ville de de
donner aux réfugiés des logements qui
sont en attente dans le secteur social
pour des gens qui attendent depuis très
longtemps un logement puisque ça
créerait forcément des mécontentements
et ça serait pas juste il faut trouver
d'autres solutions il y a on aura
peut-être une à proposer il y a un vrai
besoin social justement sur la commune
vous vous disiez faut pas que ce se
fasse au détriment des besoins là déjà
il y a des dossiers en attente sur à peu
près 350 à 400 personnes en attente
effectivement si des réfugiés arrivaient
ça mettrait encore plus de retard dans
après il y a le contingent aussi
préfectoral donc c'est aussi au préfet
sur son contingent de prendre les
dispositions nécessaires mais sur notre
contingent effectivement qui n'est que
de 20 % ça sera très difficile à
entendre pour la population et surtout
les gens qui sont en attendre de
logement juste vous disiez s en
réflexion vous allez vous décider quand
sur l'accueil des réfugiés ça passer en
conseil municipal c'est
décision j'ai une proposition à faire
aux élus donc je la feris et dans les
jours qui viennent et donc on a voilà on
va on va en discuter ensemble sachez que
c'est des sujets effectivement qui amène
beaucoup de débats et les débats sont
légitimés on va s'arrêter un petit peu
plus sur votre commune justement cette
ville des clés sous-bois vous l'avez
découverte quand parle de votre élection
en 95 dans l'opposition mais vous vous
êtes installé quand au cl al moi je suis
installé en 87 au clésousbois 1987
complètement par hasard complètement par
hasard je cherche originaire de
Saint-Germain en lait on cherchait donc
une plutôt une une maison du côté de
Saint-Germain et les prix étaient déjà
extrêmement élevés et par hasard
l'agence nous a fait visiter une une
maison au cassouois et à l'époque je
travaillais sur Paris j'étais chez chez
Delsa bobini dans l'export et donc on a
voilà on a on a choisi de et cette vie
vous plaisit vous êtes venu là par DESP
parce que c'était moins cher non non non
on a surtout le casad de vie c'est une
ville assez proche de de Paris he par le
par le train avec beaucoup de de forêts
beaucoup d'espace vert puisque la ville
fait 11 hectares mais la moitié est en
espace vert et en forêt vous l'avez
changé proximité de Paris proximité de
Saint-Germain de versaill mais vous
l'avez changé cette ville c'est ce qu'on
dit vousz beaucoup changé je pense qu'on
l'a changé ou parce que vous êtes arrivé
on parle souvent des centres commerciaux
qui sont installés des immeubles qui se
sont construits aussi oui je regrette
qu'on parle pas assez souvent d'ailleurs
de nos entreprises parce que nous avons
trois leaders mondiaux sur les clés de
trois entreprises mondiales don un Tech
qui est en train de s'agrandir et qui va
prendre 200 personnes envoyer 200
nouvelles personnes on a bien sûr
l'ancien Bull qui est àos aussi et
d'autres d'autres sociétés qui sont
aussi leaders européens leader mondial
donc euh mais donc voilà il y a pas que
les centres commer mais c'est vrai qu'on
parle du commerce parce que c'est ce
qu'on voit le plus aussi forcément et
les immeubles pour les pour les logement
c'est votre bagage commercial justement
qui vous a donné envie de d'implanter
plus de commerce dans cette commune
c'est surtout créer de l'emploi c'est
créer de l'emploi parce que quand on n'a
pas d'emploi on n' pas de logement ou on
trouve pas de logement et je pense que
l'emploi est une priorité et et ça et ça
est toujours été notre notre ligne de
conduite malheureusement les gens qui
cherchent un logement s'il n'ont pas
d'emploi ils ont très peu de chance
d'être retenus par un bailleur alors ces
décisions toutes ces constructions ces
changements que vous avez mis en place
quelquefois ça fait grincer quelques
dents 30 juin de cette année 150
personnes qui manifestent devant la
mairie lors du conseil municipal
puisqu'il n'était pas d'accord sur le
déplacement de la halle du marché la
fermeture du centre de loisirs des
Bruyères aussi pour faire une résidence
pour personnes âgées depuis ça s'est
calméou alors je ne sais pas mais nous
avons une réunion publique qui est
organisée la semaine prochaine justement
pour les entendre en fait comme vous
l'avez dit c'est simplement le
déplacement d'un centre de loisir pour
ce qui est des Bruyères nous avions un
comment dire un projet de réhabilité de
reconstruction du nouveau centre de
loisir qui existe d'un nouveau centre de
loisir puisque celui qui existe est très
très vituste et il s'est avéré que nous
avons réalisé parf depuis quelques
années une étude globale de l'offre au
niveau de du du scolaire il s'avère que
nous avons par un cabinet d'audit nous
avons deux écoles qui sont quasiment
vide d'entreut dans le quartier nord
nous avons une baisse de la
fréquentation dans certaines écoles et
et nous avons donc proposé nous allons
choisi de de plutôt que de mettre 5
millions dans la construction d'un
nouveau centre de loisir à une époque où
on va en entendre parler je crois
beaucoup le 19 septembre avec la
mobilisation des mares toutes les
communes sont en difficultés financières
nous avons voilà voilà nous souhaitons
donc transférer les enfants dans une des
écoles qui sera totalement qui sera vide
et réaménagé pour les accueillir dans
les mêmes conditions possibles dans le
quartier Nord mais visiblement malgré
les explications ça passe pas toujours
auprès de la population
ça pour dire que quand on fait de la
politique il faut aussi se dire on peut
pas plaire à tout le monde vous en avez
pris votre partie ou non je pense que
nous avons peut-être pas été assez
pertinent sur la communication on a
certainement faot oui mais tous les
jours hein voilà n modeste en polique il
faut avoir beaucoup d'humilité et et
surtout pas de certitude donc voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on avance et le et
donc oui oui donc je pense que nous
avons pêché sur la communication il y a
deux soucis il y a l'inquiétude des
parents qui ont peur que leurs enfants
et un espace ver réduit mais on fera les
aménagements nécessaires et puis il y a
également des des personnes qui sont des
riverins qui souhaitent garder aussi un
poumon vert dans le quartier donc on a
entendu ces deux demandes il faut savoir
que la nouvelle organisation d'étape a
complètement modifié le système
de d'accueil périscolaire puisque
maintenant ils ont plac ce mercredi et
que cet accueil qui va être transféré
maintenant ne recueille plus que 80
enfants puisque la plupart maintenant
sont accueillis sur site c'est-à-dire
dans les écoles voilà dans la nouvelle
l'école Victor Hugo que nous avions
construit il y a 90 enfants qui sont en
périscolaire et en voilà centre de
loisirs sur cette école ce que pensent
les habitants de votre commune on a posé
la question à quelquesuns d'entre eux je
vous laisse écouter ce microir d'accord
merci beaucoup je suis très contente
d'être au clés on fait des belles choses
pour les personnes du 3e âge c'est une
bonne ville les plus bah il y a plein
d'aménagements qui qui sont assez
positifs après il reste encore à faire
pas mal de choses il manque des
boutiques que ce soit une ville un peu
plus vivante
je suis né ici donc ça a beaucoup changé
bon il a des choses positives et
d'autres négatives les immeubles je sais
bien qu'il faut beaucoup d'immeubles
pour loger les gens mais ça enlève le
charme quand même elle est assez
sympathique beaucoup de commerce ouvert
et voilà le cadre de vie agréable on a
tout à proximité super pourquoi je sais
pas c'est à la fois la campagne et sans
en avoir les inconvénients et la ville
voir la grande ville é la ville est
appréciée globalement c'est ce qui
ressort des gens je m'attendais à des
critiques donc non tout va bien
visiblement non mais enfin bon on on n
pas exhaustif et vous voudriez qu'on
dise quoi de vous à la fin de votre
mandat sur les trois mandats que vous
avez pu faire euh qu'est-ce que je
voudrais qu'on dise de moi je pense que
j'étais courageuse enfin je pense que je
suis une femme courageuse qu'on se fixe
une ligne de conduite et qu'on essaie de
la tenir on a toujours été guidé par
l'intérêt général et c'est difficile
parfois de de d'expliquer à des
particuliers voilà euh j'ai on a
toujours essayé d'être juste d'être le
plus juste possible la ville est plutôt
apprécié en tout cas sur le micro
trottoir qu'on a pu faire même si bien
évidemment il y a toujours de de la
contestation comme comme partout malgré
tout est-ce que vous avez peur de perdre
l'identité de la commune avec la future
intercommunalité on va parler de
l'interco maintenant estce qu'on le
rappelle les clés sous-bois avec
Villepreux avec également plaisir ce
sont trois communes qui vont intégrer
tout l'agglomération de 50 Anseline pas
du tout c'est un vœu que que j'aimis
depuis très longtemps bien avant mais
les deux collègues pour rentrer dans
l'intercomunité de satin pas du tout
parce qu'au contraire je pense que plus
on est nombreux plus on va vers
l'intérêt général plus on cherche un
consensus une intercommunalité à 3 pour
moi ne P ne peut pas fonctionner vous
êtes opposé
d'ailleurs éé compliqué maintenant c'est
une histoire ancienne avz à discuter
entre vous parce que les discussions
étaient bloqué au moment où il y a eu la
première inter CR oui ça a été pour moi
une perte de temps une perte d'énergie
j'aurais aimé qu'on rentre dans la dans
la SK puisqu'on devait rentrer en
intercomunité on savait depuis longtemps
beaucoup plus tôt ça c'est pas fait
maintenant on c'est sur autre chose mais
je pense qu'au contraire pouvoir être
nombreux autour de la table trouver des
consensus pouvoir travailler sur un
territoire comme Saint-Quentin qui est
un territoire dynamique qui est porteur
d'emploi qui est porteur de compétition
internationale qui est voilà c'est pour
nous c'est une c'est un projet ambition
que nous avons à monter et nous sommes
très heureux mais actuellement vous êtes
en train de discuter parce que c arrivée
dans l'interco c'est 1er janvier 2016
sauf s'il a des dérogations dans la loi
mais enfin ça semble peu probable vu le
le calendrier qui reste euh perdre voir
les les compétences qui vont s'organiser
perdre certaines compétences pour la
commune en voir d'autres dans
l'agglomération là vous discutez
actuellement oui tout à fait c'est une
révolution parce que nous rentrons
d'abord nous avons rentrons dans une
intercommunaité qui existe depuis 40 ans
enfin qui s'est constitué comme ça un
comité d'aglo un ancien San et nous
rentrons d'une part fusion avec deux
communes ce qui sont les clés et plaisir
et puis et villepre pardon et morpa qui
rentre en commune individuelle donc
c'est un petit peu difficile on rentre
avec une histoire qui est complètement
différente de de de la leure de
l'histoire de 5 en puisque se sont créés
comme ça dès le départ et nous on a une
histoire avec un patrimoine historique
avec les habitudes et
ceteraagglomération Saint-Quentin
absorbe beaucoup de compétences des
compétences dites facultatives alors
après il y a eu des par exemple la
culture qui a été prise même si la
nouvelle équipe a décidé de mettre moins
de budget sur la culture des choses
comme ça c'est des orientations dont
vous discutez
actuellementè voà compétences là c'est
la meririe qui garde c'est pas laation
après les discussions sont en cours
comme vous dites il y a des compétences
qui sont obligatoires après reste aussi
à définir l'intérêt communautaire je
pense que c'est aussi l'occasion pour la
la casqui de toiletter peut-être
certaines et de revoir aussi son
fonctionnement et pour vous vous avez
des conditions oui sur quel
point on les on les exprime pour le
moment en privé Enad voilà pour le
moment privé oui on a quelques
convictions oui quelques
interrogations il vont être difficile à
faire évoluer non ça se passe bien les
discussions qui aura le dernier mot bah
de toute façon je pense qu'il y aura un
vote oui voilà donc voilà forcément ça
se réglera par vote ça se réglera par
vote oui ouioui qu'attendent les
habitants de cette intercommunalité
justement même chose nous sommes allés
leur poser la question à mon avis ça va
nous coûter un peu cher je pense qu'on
aurait mieux fait mais malheureusement
on nait pas le droit c'était de faire
avec versaill quoi avec le grand
versaill je crois que c'est une petite
ville qui est presque comme PL qui est
et que bon disons que si ça peut
apporter un peu de travail en plus ce
serait une bonne chose hein pour la
ville je ne vois pas précisément bon
est-ce qu'on doit faire des économies
peut-être en joignant les questions pour
les
personnels ça fera moins de moins
d'emploi peut-être ici pour la commune
je pense que ça va peut-être favoriser
l'emploi je crois savoir que
Saint-Quentin est la deuxème zone
d'emploi après la défense donc pour moi
je pense que beaucoup d'employeurs
pourraient venir s'installer à
Saint-Quentin ça ça une je pense que ça
représente quelque chose pour nous et
puis peut-être du coup donner un un
envol pour le un essur pour le
transport ça va coûter cher l'interco
c'est ce qui inquiète he le plus alors
le plus c'est on se dit oui ça va faire
des nouveaux emplois ouis si on prend ce
que dit la Cour Régionale des Comptes il
y a pas d'intercommunité qui permett
vraiment de réaliser des économies alors
ça sert à rien euh au final au moins au
début il y a un souci de mutualisation
mais qui se fait dans le temps euh je
parle entre autres des transferts de
personnel parce que vous comprendz bien
que les voilà on va pas on ne peut pas
retirer des postes donc même si on
enencrait pas donc au moins dans
l'immédiat il y a pas forcément des
économies par contre en conditions
d'amélioration de qualité de oui la dame
a parlé des transports oui ce qui nous
importe nous on a un réseau de bus qui
est vraiment qui s'est amélioré mais qui
n'est pas encore très satisfaisant et
pouvoir justement bénéficier de bus la
nuit davantage de transport et cetera
c'est important donc ça peut coûter cher
ça va coûter cher mais c'est un
investissement pour l'avenir je ne sais
pas exactement comment ça va coûter cher
puisque ça va être aussi en fonction des
dotations de de l'État mais si celle-ci
continue à diminuer ça peut
effectivement coûter cher ce sera votre
votre combat sur ce mandat cette
intercommunalité en tout cas ça va
occuper une part importante de de ce
mandat est-ce que ce sera votre dernier
mandat ce sera mon dernier mandat j'ai
annoncé quand je me suis présenté aux
électeurs pour qu'il sache que je me
présentais pour la la dernière fois donc
ça a été dit dès le départ et après vous
arrêtez la politique après je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas ça dépendra des des
défis qui me seront
proposés é
r toutes possibilités ouvertes les
régionales pourrai m'intéresser puis bon
je si à Paris Métropole depuis longtemps
et et je commence à avoir une certaine
connaissance effectivement de de la
région et ça veut dire vous NZ pas avoir
plus de temps pour vous occuper de votre
passion votre passion ce sont les
Indiens d'Amérique parce qu'on en a pas
parlé ah oui
tout à fait ouais c'est une part de ma
vie que j'ai mis un petit peu entre
parenthèses mais que je
rouvriraai je pense plus tard et voilà
et c'est quelque chose effectivement qui
me manque beaucoup et quand je peux
j'essaie de m'échapper parce que vous
l'avez dit vous arrivez dans la ville
des clés sousbois vous êtes élu dans
l'opposition et puis après vous partez
aux États-Unis vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et c'est pendant ce voyage aux
États-Unis cette vie aux États-Unis
pendant 4 ans que vous découvrez les
Indiens d'Amérique donc comment ça s'est
fait cette rencontre un petit peu par
hasard le conseiller culturel de
l'époque de l'ambassade quel de
passionné qui a vécu avec des Indiens et
qui nous a moment donné o on partait en
vacances pendant des grandes vacances
qui nous a indiqué des endroits aller et
on s'est tout de suite retrouvé au
milieu des tribus dans les for corners
on a vécu avec eux on a vu des sorciers
on est allé à des cérémonies rituelles
et après tout s'est enchaîné j'ai monté
à Washington une association justement
pour avec avec des Indiens et qu'est-ce
qui vous a
séduit le le leur spiritualité leur
spiritualité c'est des gens qui ont qui
sont très attaché à la terre aux
ancêtres au respect au respect de la
terre à l'environnement et et
aussi oui à nos ancêtres on est là parce
que on a eu des des des ancêtres on aura
des enfants le cycle de la
vie collectionnez des objets des des
chosesou dans votre bureau dans la
passionnée j'ai failli ramener un tipi
mais pas dansard ouais non je me suis
dit ça va faire des ordres quand même
une nouvelle construction compr et autre
engagement juste pour terminer dont on n
pas parlé parce que vous avez été dans
le collège des assistants du Défenseur
des droits pour les enfants parce que ça
on l'a pas mentionné c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui hein non parce que
malheureusement tous les membres du
collège ont été
renouvelés à l'issue du décès de
Dominique Bodis puisque c'est c'est la
loi qui qui prévoit cette façon de
fonction mais comment vous êtz arrivé
sur ce sur ce poste parce que c'est
domin Bodis effectivement qui vous avit
nommé oui non c'est Gérard il y avait
trois contingents de je crois que
c'était six personnes et j'étais nommé
sur le contingent de du président du
Sénat qui étaitarché il y avait le
compteagent président de l'Assemblée
nationale et le compteagent du président
de la République alors pourquoi vous
aviez une une sensibilité particulière
sur cette question là parce que il
paraît que mon indépendance de vue me
permettait de rester justement comment
dire pragmatique sur les questions qui
éta qui étaient posées et je suis une
femme de combat aussi de de conviction
voilà femme de combat et indépendante et
de conviction mê même au sein de votre
propre partie vous restez indépendante
vous savez être critique quand il faut
être critique
je voilà c'est une liberté que j'ai
souvent payé cher mais je je souhaite la
garder des regrets non non quand vous
dites vous l'avez payé cher par exemple
parce que effectivement quand on est
libre on
dérange au même de votre partie on vous
a dit maintenant ça suffit on a oui on a
on a on a beaucoup en politique de
partout d'ailleurs c'est pas un milieu
ce n'est pas un milieu facile mais il
vous plaît quand même ce milieu oui
parce que c'est passionnant c'est
passionnant il y aucun jour ne se
ressemble faut voilà mais par contre il
faut être solide il faut être solide et
puis pouvoir prendre du recul c'est pour
ça que la communication d'ailleurs est
très difficile parce qu'on est dans dans
un monde maintenant où la communication
est immédiate des mails tout va très
vite et on ne prend pas le temps de la
réflexion voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
quelquefois je pense qu'il faut différer
les réponses plutôt que de réagir ou
dans l'émotion ou dans l'urgence mercion
je vous en prie merci
beaucoup
[Musique]